[Musik]
wir produzieren gerade die kranken der
zukunft die situation ist für den bürger
teilweise nicht nachvollziehbar am
meisten würde ich mir wünschen dass wir
wieder in gruppen trainieren können der
politischen debatte wird meines
erachtens nach die rolle des sports und
auch der bewegung nicht genug
wahrgenommen
[Musik]
ja seit der krone pandemie im märz 2020
erster lockdown und jetzt im zweiten
block da und steht eigentlich das leben
hier still
es gibt kaum menschen in unseren
sportstätten in einigen sportstätten gar
nichts haben wir komplett geschlossen
traurige trostlose situation wenn man
hier durch die sportanlagen geht und
nichts und das leben ist nicht da mein
name ist boris schmidt ich bin
vorsitzender der turn- und
sportgemeinschaft bergedorf und bin hier
im verein seit knapp 34 jahren also wir
haben 17 prozent ungefähr 1700
mitglieder verloren in dieser zeit dass
das ganz aufgehört hat war fatal
wir haben auch kinder dadurch verloren
was den sport angeht und die eltern
haben irgendwann auch keine lust mehr
nun kommen noch und nun macht doch und
wenn dann immer nur mäßig kennt wird
nervt mich nicht diese situation war für
alle nicht einfach weil natürlich der
spaß mit der gruppe im vordergrund
besteht sich zu treffen soziale kontakte
auszuleben und da habe ich schon hohen
leidensdruck bei vielen leuten
wahrgenommen und enormen auch bei
kindern und jugendlichen also es war
halt immer etwas gefehlt neben der
schule wenn man die ganze zeit zu hause
saß hat ihm das gefühl noch mal
rauskommen kann sport machen kann und
fragen wo man natürlich auch die
mannschaft gefehlt
[Musik]
die situation ist für den bürger
teilweise nicht nachvollziehbar
also ist findet auch keine akzeptanz
wenn ich es überall anders ist nehmen
sie eine fußball c jugendmannschaft das
ist genau dieser altersklasse 13 14
jährige
das steht holstein davon wenn man 14 ist
aber dass 15 lebensjahr noch nicht
erreicht hat noch mitspielen in hamburg
nicht ein trainer muss der hälfte der
mannschaft erklären
du bleibst zu hause und die andere
hälfte die das training haben halt immer
als in sohland aufgeteilt natürlich
schade dass man einander nicht sehen
kann aber immerhin steht die möglichkeit
dass man spielen kann ich will das gar
nicht anprangern dass sie fußball
nationalmannschaft durch die welt
tingeln kann
das ist eine andere baustelle aber warum
dürfen wir denn hier nicht mit 20
kindern spielen und wir passen laufen
und sind auch getestet
aber da ist es erlaubt und der fokus
liegt darauf und es wird berichtet alles
ist toll alles super aber der breiten
amateur sport geht unter leider in der
politischen debatte wird meines
erachtens nach die rolle des sports und
auch der bewegung nicht genug
wahrgenommen insbesondere in bezug auf
kinder und jugendliche
[Musik]
wir haben inzwischen hier mause er ein
eigenes zentrum eingerichtet wir wissen
natürlich auch das ist keine
hundertprozentige garantie aber es ist
ein richtiger schritt
und wenn wir tagesaktuell testen dann
sehe ich keinen grund warum wir kontakt
arme sportarten wie tennis wie badminton
warum wird diese nicht in kleineren
gruppen und den kleineren größen schon
durchführen dürfen
[Musik]
der organisierte sport hat eigentlich
von anfang an sich aufgemacht und hat
hygiene konzepte entwickelt und
vorschläge erarbeitet die auch bei uns
von anfang an super gegriffen haben und
da hätte ich mir auch gewünscht von der
politik dass man in den sport rein geht
das halt auch mal erfragt und überprüft
oder evaluiert wie das gelaufen ist
[Musik]
also wenn ich wirklich mir das handeln
der politik mal so revue passieren der
letzten monate hat ist es ja sehr stark
durch ängste geprägt es geht eher um
reduktion und verbote alles um
lösungsstrategien und mögliche wege
[Musik]
im produzieren gerade die kranken die
zukunft warum weil wir jetzt aktuell
reiz eben nicht setzen die der körper
aber benötigt und bestimmte krankhafte
prozesse eben nicht einzuleiten und ich
mich sicher davon aus dass wir im jahr
2030 eine verdoppelung unserer
krankheits ausgaben sozial ökonomisch
also ein super gau haben wenn wir sehen
wie kinder wenn sie zum beispiel bald
treffen einfach uns an grinsen die arme
hoch reisen als hätten sie wimbledon
gewonnen und dieses gefühl für also gib
mir immer so eine gänsehaut moment wo
ich denke genau das ist es was ich
erreichen möchte einfach dass sie
glücklich sind und spaß an der bewegung
mein name ist andreas stark ich leite
mit meinem mann hier die tennisschule in
nauheim und bin jetzt mittlerweile seit
zehn jahren hier nauheim als trainerin
tätig also als wir die nachricht
erhalten haben dass der erste lockout
kommt und wird tatsächlich hier die
halle zu schließen mussten und kein
training mehr stattfinden durfte muss
ich gestehen habe ich ein paar tränen
verdrückt weil ich auch diejenige war
die zu schließen musste und das war ein
furchtbarer moment in vielen vereinen
ist zurzeit leider ein stillstand
entstanden und die vereine leiden
darunter sehr weil sie natürlich gerne
mit den menschen zusammen ihren sport
ausüben wollen jetzt nach einem jahr
pandemie kann man schon deutlich sagen
dass also die mitgliederzahlen über alle
vereine und über alle altersgruppen
rückläufig sind
besonders dramatisch ist es bei den
kindern und jugendlichen
da haben wir bei der altersgruppe bis 18
knapp sieben prozent rückläufe und bei
den kindern bis sechs jahren sind es 17
prozent
und das ist für uns schon alarmierend
für die kinder sind die beschränkung
total schwierig und die fassen ist auch
ganz unterschiedlich auf manche haben
sich komplett zurückgezogen haben gesagt
wir spielen jetzt erst mal nicht und
warten ab was passiert
andere waren regelmäßig hier und haben
das angebot genutzt was der verein ihnen
geboten hat ja also es ist schon anders
wenn man nach dem training nicht
zusammen da sitzen kann es am meisten
würde ich mir wünschen dass wir wieder
in gruppen trainieren können auch mal
mit mehreren wenn man sich an die
abstände hält und diese drei meter
einhält dann ich kann kinder hier
hintereinander stellen die vierergruppe
und kann auf 600 quadratmeter kann ich
die zehn meter auseinander stellen und
kann ganz normales training machen und
im freien sehe ich da keine probleme bei
den meisten sportarten die personen
freien betreiben ist das
infektionsrisiko außerordentlich gering
das liegt daran dass sicherheit diese
viren mit denen wir es gerade zu tun
haben durch erosion übertragen das heißt
durch das ausatmen kleinste tröpfchen
die dann der andere einatmet und da
braucht man eine gewisse dosis ist eine
gewisse menge muss man da ab bekommen um
sich zu infizieren
und die erreicht man im freien nicht
weil dieses epos holt sich im freien
sofort stark verdünnt
wir versuchen immer wieder die
öffentlichkeit zu suchen und
aufmerksamkeit zu erregen
es ist einfach wichtig dass die dass man
versteht wie diese übertragung
stattfindet dass man dieses euro soll
geschehen versteht
[Musik]
gerade jetzt in den letzten tagen ist
eine ganz große analyse aus irland
erschienen
dort sind 232.000 infektionen untersucht
worden
und von denen fanden gerade mal 260 im
freien statt also die autoren schrieben
auch 99,9 prozent aller infektionen
finden in innenräumen stadt ist halt
schade dass man dieses wissen einfach
nicht praktisch umsetzen dann könnte man
viel stärkere öffnung maßnahmen
durchführen ohne eine gefährdung der
bevölkerung
[Musik]
eine altersbeschränkung für sport im
freien halte ich für überflüssig weil
das ja so gut wie keine ansteckungen im
freien gibt und dann macht natürlich
auch eine altersbeschränkung und da gar
keinen großen sinn
von daher könnte man das können wir das
auf werden also nach einem jahr pandemie
darf das nicht unser anspruch sein da
wird wir nur noch den auf- und
zuschaltungen tätig ist karsten günther
ich bin geschäftsführer beim sc dhfk
handball und das schon seit 13 jahren
sport hat eine sehr sehr hohe bedeutung
vor allen dingen sehr große tradition
auch in unserer stadt wir haben das
große privileg das war wenigstens noch
spielen dürfen
aktuell dürfen wir mit der akademie also
mit dem leistungssport trainieren also
mit unseren kader sportlern das bedeutet
gut 23 a b und c jugend wir testen die
jungs vor allem nachmittags einheiten
leider ist es so dass der kinder
sportbereich noch nicht trainieren kann
mir mit großer hoffnung gehabt dass ist
nach ostern jetzt wieder losgehen dann
das mit dem mindestens draußen mit den
kindern was machen können leider ist das
jetzt auch wieder verschoben nach einer
panne - ist der anspruch sein von einem
land der dichter und denker was ich
überhaupt technologie über forschung
über bildung über wissenschaft
auszeichnen will dass wir dort
intelligente lösung in die anwendung
bringt
wir haben die restart 19 studie
angestoßen um wirklich zu erforschen was
was machen veranstaltungen in pandemie
zeiten wirklich aus in den risiko unter
welchen bedingungen sind sie
durchführbar
ich glaube dass veranstaltungen während
der pandemie möglich sind aber das
hygiene konzept der veranstaltung muss
zur jeweiligen situation passen und ich
glaube dass wir den leuten auch ein
stück weit eine perspektive geben können
mit solchen veranstaltungen
wenn man es sicher durchführt aber nicht
alles so wurde es verbietet wir haben
eigene konzepte entwickelt hierfür die
arena wo wir sagen wir teilen die arena
im quadranten 1
die zuschauer drehten jeweils in einem
quadranten 1 bleiben in diesem
quadranten wir haben einen gewissen
abstand der abstand richtet sich
zwischen den zuschauern dann auch am
jeweiligen incidents aus wir haben es
bei einigen spielen vom sc dhfk im
herbst getestet und dass er erfolgreich
getestet es ging wunderbar auf wir haben
alle eine rückmeldung bekommen dass sich
irgendjemand infiziert hatte
veranstaltungen sind in pandemie zeiten
sicher durchführbar wenn man sich an
gewisse regeln hält die im einklang
stehen müssen mit den jeweiligen
incidents werden
das hat die studie ganz klar gezeigt die
werden weltweit angewendet leider in
deutschland noch nahezu komplett
ignoriert das ist sehr sehr bitter
letztlich fehlt glaube ich ein schritt
der mut das jetzt auch umzusetzen und
das finde ich schade
[Musik]
ich finde dass auf jeden fall ziemlich
schlimm wenn es jetzt wieder einen
lockout geben würde wo man gar kein
tennis mehr spielen kann
ich kann das nicht noch mal
also wenn das jetzt noch mal runter
fährt dann wird die kleine kinderseele
das nicht so gut vertragen auch ich aber
es würde es nicht verstehen ich würde es
nicht nachvollziehen können aktuell hat
man das gefühl dass niemand mehr so
richtig zuhört dass viel mehr in schwarz
und weiß kategorien gedacht wird und das
ist nur auf oder zu und dazwischen gibt
es nichts
körperliche aktivität und sport ist eine
der wichtigsten motoren um gesund vital
und leistungsfähig zu bleiben
genau das klären wir gerade um
letztendlich haben wir gerade eine
bewegungsmangel pandemie und das ist
schon ganz absurd
[Musik]